rise and shine yeah kylie jenner's rise
and shine song is still a thing and yes
we still can't stop singing it thank you
now Kylie's big brother Rob Kardashian
is joining in on the viral craze the
reality star shared this clip of his
little sis on Instagram
that's Kylie standing in the living room
silently reenacting her famous tune and
just in case you couldn't make out what
Kylie was mouthing Rob captioned the
clip quote rise and shine
of course the hit moment came from this
video of Kylie giving a tour of her
Kylie cosmetics office this is the
official Kylie cosmetic tour at the end
of the tour the beauty mogul takes fans
inside her daughter Stormy's at work
nursery where she flips the light on and
well just listen for yourself and get
out of here and show you guys no room
surprised and shiny and just like that a
me moment was born let's play it again
it's just too good surprise and shiny
both fans and trolls have posted remixes
and covers of rise and shine rise and
shine
rise and shine rise and shine
surprise and shiny surprise and shiny
surprise and shine even some celebs got
in on the fun ariana grande shared this
video to her insta story whose rise and
shine Miley Cyrus shared this meme of
The Voice coaches turning their chairs
to Kiley song rise and shine
[Music]
then she sang the tune with her new boo
Cody Simpson Mindy Kaling shared this
pic of herself on Twitter writing a rise
and shine and even stormy got down to
the jam yes of course Kylie being the
business boss lady that she is decided
to monetize the viral moment and now you
can buy rise and shine merch including
this hoodie with the lyrics yes I'm
serious and this ladies and gents is how
you become the youngest self-made
billionaire she works really hard she
made her own money for over a decade she
put it in the bank
she saved every nickel it's not like
that was handed to her she figured that
all out rise and shine res and shut ah I
still can't stop of course
et will be right here to bring you all
the viral kardashian-jenner moments so
make sure to keep it locked right here
until next time I'm Holly Stevens bye
for now
[Music]
you